for more than half a century the mirandy
bridge spanned the gorge that bisects
the northern Italian port town of Genoa
[Music]
on Tuesday during a heavy storm 200
metres of the middle span simply gave
way plunging 45 metres into the valley
below taking with it dozens of vehicles
and many lives this amazing big roar and
it was raining so I thought it was
enlightening and I saw the bridge in the
days that followed Italy has immersed
itself in the emotional mix of grief and
anger but in the immediate aftermath
rescue is the priority yes of course we
are involved as humans but we are first
of all rescues so in this moment we have
to try to do our best in order to save
what we can save and who we can save of
course and there will be a time later to
you know to debrief and to try to
understand what is this situation what
was to feel and to leave the situation
fire crews construction teams and
sniffer dogs clambering over the
mountains of mangled steel and concrete
searching for survivors day and night
well we are working under a heap of
debris and as you see behind us the
bridges collapsed and we are now
searching or people under debris and big
voids you can find them and looking in
such been the car it's at his prime
minister Giuseppe Conte visited the
scene in the hours after the collapse
it's necessary that the maintenance is
even more strict in the checks are even
more punctual and rigorous we must
prevent such tragedies from happening
all citizens should be able to travel
safely and we will work to prevent this
from happening again
the initial horror of what happened is
captured in this image a lone truck
abandoned having literally run out of
Road as the morandi folded in front of
it the rescue teams were working in the
most difficult of conditions some
plucked from the debris dangling on the
end of a rope
yet there were those who walked away
it looked early on as if the driver of
this lorry flattened by falling masonry
couldn't have survived yet with only a
broken arm Luciani Oh gotcha was back at
his vehicle to claim his belongings
under the bridge I opened the door of
the truck to get out and I heard a loud
noise and then nothing when I turned I
saw myself moving towards the wall and I
couldn't breathe in the pressure wave
moved me I'm a miraculous survivor
others reflected on their good fortune
and how close they've come to being
among the dead or injured think Beaufort
- an ad I consider myself more than
lucky because had I passed by five
minutes later I wouldn't be here talking
about walked under it every day twice a
day I passed over it once a day like
everyone here in magenta it's one of the
principal roads through the city I don't
know how this could have happened
marina Julie otter was sheltering from
the rain under the bridge with her
daughter when it collapsed and buried
them both yeah man all a better later
when I woke up I was stuck in the rubble
and I was holding my daughter's hand but
I couldn't see her because she was
completely buried the firefighters
started to dig her out her face was
turned to the ground and I saw the
rescuers pulling rubble out of her mouth
to allow her to breathe Gianluca adeney
clung to dangling wires 20 meters above
the ground for hours before rescuers got
to him his pregnant girlfriend Julia
Organo said was the thought of their
unborn baby that gave him the strength
to hang on Roberto Robbie ah no his wife
a Celia Puccini no and their
seven-year-old son Sam well II also died
mr. Robbie our know posted a photo of
the three of them on holiday in Sardinia
just hours before they were killed
Alberto Fonfon II and his girlfriend
Marta Danny C were killed too when the
bridge collapsed he was an anesthetist
who worked in Pisa she a nurse from
Sicily
Andrea Cheerilee a keen amateur
footballer dad and husband lost his life
as he made his way to work at Genoa
sport his colleagues say his loss has
hit them hard
we are a family of 1,100 workers who are
dazed and confused depressed is not a
worker who died by brother and a friend
who lost his life as the rescue effort
continued without let-up questions were
being asked about how such a catastrophe
could have happened was an accident
incompetence or profiteering that led to
such a great loss of life
Giuseppe Conte focused on the highway
company we will move independently and
we will act in order to revoke the
concession to the company autostrad
because there is no doubt that given the
present system and the current agreement
it was autostrad who had the burden the
mirandy bridge was constructed in the
1960s is designed not unique but rare
and that too may have made the structure
vulnerable to failure according to
experts it's quite a young bridge but
about the project there were a lot of
concerns since the very beginning on
this kind of project only three bridges
were built around words and the other
two already had serious problems so most
technicians advised that it was to be
stopped - there had been some
refurbishment of the giant supports
recently but to the untrained eye that
work looks partial and other sections
appear rusty beyond it they're gone some
of those that live near the Morandi have
never felt it was safe when I passed the
bridge all times I have a fear because
no safe the interior minister Matteo
salvini spent time with some of the
injured in hospital before laying into
the bridge operator once again Mercato
if I was a manager of autostrada
I would have been here for two days and
I would have opened my wallet and give
my millions of euros profit to the
people damaged by this tragedy the
viaduct spans both an industrial zone
and a residential neighbourhood 600
people have been moved out of their
homes being allowed to retrieve their
valuables with emergency
DMC Safinaz Tomatina until this morning
we wholly had the clothes we were
wearing then nothing else not even a
brush the firefighters took us to the
house they gave us some time an hour so
we could collect some stuff safer safer
is another who had to move out of his
flat with his wife and children this is
my balcony he lives right underneath the
bridge here's the bridge when I went to
him
that house when the first day I went
inside they my son who told me that he
if that comes down I was laughing
because it was something impossible that
that comes down and four days ago
my son told me do you remember that I
told you in an exhibition centre the
coffins of many of the Dead await the
state funeral this weekend friends and
relatives in private thought before a
public good by a local priest says what
happened to general this week has
wounded the entire city this bridge long
to our everyday life fast enemies will
cross it every day is it used to link to
past the city to go out of Genoa to go
on vacation or to go anywhere if we used
to always go out of the city over that
bridge it belongs to every Genovese
[Applause]
but there have already been some
funerals away from Genoa the families of
these four friends from Naples blame the
state for their deaths
the mirandy bridge can be rebuilt or
replaced but for the families of those
who were killed when the huge structure
fell apart there can never be a
substitute for what they lost last
Tuesday